hello and welcome im sue me so Miss
Conda and this is world stories your
international reporters magazine thanks
for joining us on this edition we find
out if elephant and man can live in
harmony at the foothills of the
Himalayas we learn about a traditional
dance in Iraq and how modern technology
can transport us into the distant past
in Australia all that and more but first
it's estimated that one in every 1,000
babies around the globe is born with
Down syndrome it's a condition where
extra genetic material causes
intellectual and physical disabilities
but those disabilities come in varying
degrees and many people with Down
syndrome do lead very fulfilling and
even independent lives in our next story
Alena rozonda from brazil's rey de minas
TV shows us how activity and training
have created a world of opportunities
for people with Down syndrome
strength balance technique
determination
all important ingredients for a
successful dive
doctors recommend regular swimming to
help people affected by Down syndrome
improve motor function and coordination
alessandra trains under his father are
nando's constant supervision he gives
his son tips here making sure he stays
relaxed
the desire to see his son winsford
Raimondo on at 32 alessandra has won
bronze silver and gold medals in several
events and stood on the winner's podium
in both his native Brazil and abroad
Alicia Alessandra is there a medal
you're especially proud of what's the
thing my scouting you put it is which
one both the strength yes but which
medal is the most important Twitter
meter freestyle and where did your win
it Wayne Coyne bro coimbra in Portugal
alessandra is an only child his parents
were nearly 40 when he was born des que
nació Posada primera sofa after the
first shock we were truly quite
surprised we were very happy that he
came into our lives gia and to this day
he's our end all and be all he's our
life loss of you
parents are always on the look out for
what's best for their children each
family has to decide how to best support
and motivate them job skills courses can
teach children with Down syndrome how to
be more independent lies independence
now judge bothersome so you're in a
waiting room and we're going to simulate
a job interview it's an important moment
you can get nervous what does walking
back and forth show that's you're
nervous that's right it's normal to be
nervous but you have to try to control
it that kind of advice is important for
all those who want to take on the
challenge of facing the job market in
space a Buick we've seen it until now
their parents always held the reins they
had the documents planned appointments
and made agreements and so on and that's
counterproductive in the working world
the course was set up by Catholic
University of meanness grass it's
designed to help students become more
independent and the results are
impressive it took Tiago 27 years to
take the bus home on his own now his
only companion is his courage do you
like to travel alone yes why well
traveling alone means a lot okay well I
thought I loved it what's that say you
feel more independent with independent a
change SI ankles after me each
successful integration into society is a
personal success shortly after students
finish the course they call and tell me
they found work and have put what
they've learned into practice there they
tell me they've learned a lot here or
they come back to class and tell the
pupils about their experiences since
both are capable cool space rather
quantized experience apples and it makes
me very happy oh boy if someone forgot
to figure to surrender I'm sorry could
we cut here
an inspiring example for all of us now
to the story of a university professor
in Istanbul who's become a successful
entrepreneur I tool air so is the
founder and CEO of this tech is revision
a pioneer in industrial image processing
in turkey emerging stars TV sits down
with Professor air soul and finds out
how she transformed an idea into a
thriving company and how she balances
the demands of running a business with
those of her classroom take a look
you
Istanbul Turkey education is essential
and one of the foundations of
entrepreneurship so what happens when a
professor becomes an entrepreneur is she
then a perfect role model and an
immediate success let's find out here at
fistic a company which uses smart camera
based systems CEO and founder I tour
essel explains
mystic is a spinoff from Savannah
University we are experts in computer
vision and what does that mean computer
vision is analyzing images and trying to
make some sense out of it so we
concentrate on mostly manufacturing
automation type of applications but we
also have none industrial applications
like the gender designation face
recognition activity monitoring so in
essence it's just analyzing images and
making some sense out of this tech
vision creates state-of-the-art
solutions using machine vision
technology for modern production lines
where productivity and quality assurance
are essential
this is an application in automotive
industry where they want to match the
wheels with Williams so they have lots
of different kinds of Williams like 36
different kinds and then like they have
about 20 different wheels and they want
to put the correct wheels on the correct
wielder so we have two systems one
camera looking at the wheel them one
camera plus the laser looking at the
wheel and the difficulty is we're doing
this while the tire is spinning at a
rate of five hundred sixty rounds per
minute so we need the writing's on the
wheel and we also recognize the william
type and see if they match or not dr. i
tol aircel founded this deck in 2006
surfing on you commercial trends well I
saw the need because in Turkey these
type of things technology didn't exist
that when I started there were no
companies who were building applications
with this they were importing from
abroad especially Germany but there were
no companies in Turkey so I decided
there was an opportunity there there was
a need there so I formed the company I
too was one of the top students in
Turkey she went to the USA to finish a
masters and returned to turkey to teach
it's a banshee University and follow her
dream are starting her own company the
university was actually apartment at the
beginning
because our university is very
entrepreneurial university like Silicon
Valley was founded from technology from
Stanford so our University wanted to do
that they founded a company called in
event and they wanted to be partnered in
they wanted to encourage students and
faculty members to find companies and
they didn't want to stay forever they
just wanted to stay in the company until
the company can manage on its own and
right now the university left actually
you're quite a successful businesswoman
now so why are you still teaching well I
enjoy teaching and also it keeps you in
contact with the young generation and
that brings an influx of students
graduates to the company so we get to
select the best people so I have direct
access to the best people and also you
know we follow what's going on in
technologically we go to conferences so
the university is there very beneficial
I told herself she's found the perfect
resource for experts for her company her
students at the University she's also
been selected by endeavor an
international network organization that
supports and nurture successful
entrepreneurs and helps them grow their
business
well first of all they have a great
network so they introduce you to many
different people so in fact they say
whoever you want to meet just tell us
we'll try to find the leak so I was able
to reach people who you know I wouldn't
be able to normally and endeavour has
this emba program like this summer we
had a person from Saudi Arabia who was
an interim in our company because we
wanted to study the middle eastern
market and so she did a wonderful
analysis of the whole Middle Eastern
Market on one particular application we
had they are trying to build a strategy
you know which markets to go into what
product to concentrate on this tech
became so successful that global
companies were keen to buy it in 2009 I
told decided to sell part of the company
to is revision from Germany a leader and
computer vision for the glass industry
it's quite likely that is revision will
take full ownership of his tech in the
near future the reason was at the
beginning I wasn't really thinking of
selling but I have two daughter so I not
interested in my continuing my business
so I'm not going to live forever
something has to be done to the company
and the German company was it as good as
anyone else are you going to stay with
the company would you start of maybe
another way oh well I don't know yet but
they want me to continue in fact they
offered you to be the city of the global
oil company decided by the time comes
that will certainly be a tough choice
now to a story about an age-old conflict
man versus beast in India the population
continues to grow rapidly as towns and
cities expand and encroach on to forest
land the country's indigenous wildlife
is increasingly at risk in our next
report un TVs Mary Ferreira takes us to
a national park in the far north of the
country where wild elephants and trains
cross a dangerous situation for both
here's more
india is home to some 70,000 asian
elephants living in the heart of the
forests here but a booming population
now at a staggering 1.3 billion people
is putting these gentle giants at risk
but the pig DNA in there are a gift of
nature and we have to save them in one
hour later buggy kazutaka we don't want
to kill any animal person or elephant
Jan wad me happy moving up women of
Cecilia funny no group chant taneja
drives trains along a railway line
running through rajaji national park
where hundreds of elephants live
some 30 trains pass here daily
transporting thousands of people and
sometimes cargo across the country
in 2006 roop chance spotted a herd
crossing the track and almost hit them
party hardy there were six elephants and
one baby calf on the chart Jana when I
everything idea as tengu' the idea so I
pulled the emergency brake light you see
I was going 35 kilometers an hour we
turned on the headlights and honk the
horn and made boys are Madonna to rps
survivin wasn't it the herd moved to
safe ground but these tracks have
claimed the lives of some 20 other
elephants over the span of one decade as
they wander from the forest searching
for food gentlemen panicky funny name in
tapani be- they don't have water in the
forest so they come out here looking for
water
little Bobby J people from the train
throw food on the trucks they smelled
the food and come here to eat it John
Ruddy tied up it
nighttime is when most of the accidents
occur in this area and to protect
elephants lingering near train lines
forest officials posted patrol guards to
police the tracks yellow finish them
know the numbers when they spot
elephants coming they alert train
drivers to avoid killing the animals
this system is a temporary measure that
works well but to further protect
elephants wandering near the train lines
a more long-term solution is needed Tom
the melon air is coordinator at cities
the Convention on International trade in
endangered species which monitors the
killing of elephants worldwide if we can
build corridors that isn't one of the
ways to avoid such a human haven't
conflict more than a dozen states have
already created biological corridors the
goal is to build more of these pathways
to link ecosystems and wildlife habitats
now fragmented by human development it's
an important step towards achieving
coexistence between humans and Wildlife
an important balance to strike a la de
da is a folkloric dance in Iraq that's
performed in both happy and somber
occasions men wear traditional clothes
as they dance to the rhythm of the
accompanying drumbeats and verses it was
traditionally performed by Bedouin
tribes across the Arab world and over
the centuries the dance has even acted
as a sort of tool of diplomacy between
various clans and communities ali hassan
from of Sumeria TV tells us more about
the significance of the ad lada in Iraq
el yom tov today in this Pleasant
company that's come together we'd like
to show you a lard-ass you a traditional
form of dance from Iraq well I Lynette
had that we'll talk about differences
between the various artists and another
and another method mug and we'll discuss
the different occasions on which in our
da is performed al arabiya Alison aleaha
deburr nomination we're talking about
this custom for al Sumeria TV that what
the Colleen hello greetings to all
generous and hospitable people you are
very welcome and we're honored to have
you here greetings to the television
station moola rama lama is a traditional
Arab custom here in Iraq a person
recited a verse or poem and a group of
men dances to it either how the hustla
holla nevada can be performed on various
occasions yeah one instance is when a
chic for a friendly clamp passes away
then we organize an arthur to
commemorate the deceased other that's
performed exclusively by men lead you
man reciting the verse is always at the
head of it I momoa fell muah LOL esha
deol rry ok yeah kalma rogers you are my
strength and give me courage well on the
morrow my poetry and hospitality have
made me famous and we exceed all in
poetry and hospitality what journey our
marble my lap
nuh Ted the salon let's now talk about
the occasions on which in our da is
performed a la la la' can you tell us
about some of them talk about be hell
out of a wooden shed be here haha GG
will heartily inada is performed when
tribute is all pay to the head of a clan
off it had been when I said what it can
coincide with greater heed the Feast of
the sacrifice missin more other
celebrations for instance alone alone
aside module I had a I'm but sometimes
nada is performed to mark a blood feud
well our Allah hyun and Posada pastor
solomon universe are your loan a lien al
q valla many have tried to divide us but
we Sunnis and Shias are closing ranks to
overcome the differences between our
denominations Oh God we on a Baghdad and
its population God's mala la czuje and
hikita comparing the present to the past
there are differences in the arvest be
iPad pro pot it's now much more common
than Usain arava a cadet man haha auntie
sharon vanillish I any rockets now
spread to the west of the country has
said I'm for our best can it exist in
the areas around the cydia and tomorrow
[ __ ] up well I'm Harvath en and now yeah
lil inarius spread is due to the young
man who took the order to other regions
was that the Shebab and why has said the
kailash I nowadays it can be performed
by almost all happy and sad occasions Oh
sod of cool in menasha bot la farà
without hazard on the soul of luck
swallow you should listen carefully to
the stories I'm telling you of raising
children with love
and not hate or division honest Oliver
Luck swallow one diamond and a child
without family is truly alone and life
is as dangerous as a lion in the forest
I said my Angela we are proud of our
clan and finally when we think of Sydney
in Australia we think of a global city
of the Opera House in the harbor and the
breathtaking skyline but we rarely stop
to think of what Sydney looked like
before all those modern buildings were
around and before Europeans settled
there in our next story though we visit
an exhibition that takes us on a digital
trip back in time to the end of the 18th
century when Aboriginal peoples
inhabited the area the virtual
simulation shows us how time in history
have shaped the region a valuable lesson
for locals and visitors alike SBS
reporter many tegus has more it's one of
the most iconic areas in the world but
below these towering buildings and
concrete slabs lies something even
stronger the heritage of the gadigal
people in nearby Customs House
interactive artists Brett levy has
unveiled his latest creation a virtual
walkabout in an area once known as well
Ronnie it's a digital storytelling you
can do anything gives you ability to
build time machines it's really exciting
and the possibilities are that I can
collaborate with great people I can take
the original knowledge of the
traditional owners and I can do it in in
this way better than it's ever been done
before virtual will Ronnie to sacred
tracks of the gadigal shows what sydney
harbour used to look like before the
arrival of the first fleet in 1788 in
this 3d world lies a number of widgets
that give players access to a wealth of
stories and information now sitting here
and actually playing the game you
realize how much detail has gone into it
the developers
researched everything from the soil that
features in the ground to the marine
life that you can actually see in the
waters near by and with just the touch
of a button a few familiar landmarks
start to pop up as well among the
program's massive stream of research mr.
levy also worked with representatives of
the gadigal people who to this day
maintain a deep-seated connection with
the land they were proud of it saddened
of what it could have been like and that
sort of moves you to strive even harder
to work harder with that sort of support
overall we wanted to create an emotion
we might not get to everyone they might
not feel everyone might not feel it but
some people come away and they they they
feel that connection to the land and
this modern take on such a sacred story
already seems to be pushing the right
buttons it's pretty impressive when you
press the top button and you can see
like how is there in there nowadays
amazing like like it looks actually not
back in the days it looks like new and
stuff stories from generations past set
to last for many more many chiggers well
use Australia well that's all for this
week's edition of world stories from us
our reporters and Parker stations around
the world thanks for watching to watch
more episodes head to our website that's
DW de forward slash world stories will
leave you with this week's picks of the
world see you next time with more world
stories
Oh
the